these cute little water bears or
tardigrades are some of the hardiest
toughest animals on the planet
tardigrades have lived through all the
major mass extinctions but tardigrade
fossils that's another story because
tardigrades are so tiny most are under
one millimeter their bodies decompose
very very easily after they die leaving
behind no trace of their existence
this is a newly found tardigrade fossil
researchers called it a once in a
generation discovery
tardigrade fossils are incredibly rare
that's why javier who studies fossils of
insects and insect-like creatures like
tardigrades said he and other
paleontologists were so excited this is
only the third ever tardigrade fossil on
record and it's roughly 16 million years
old making it the youngest
it's major news because it could provide
evolutionary biologists much needed
clues about how tardigrades and life
more generally evolved on earth plus why
some species survive and others don't if
we are able to better understand the
evolution of tardigrades in our planet
we can really get a better grasp of what
are the limits of life
the tardigrades that exist today can
live in water and moss
but they can survive in the most extreme
environments
deep ocean trenches polar ice even space
javier says the long-term hope is that
understanding what makes tardigrade so
extraordinary might help us develop new
technologies that would make traveling
and living in space easier
for example during times of stress they
can squeeze out all the water out of
their tiny bodies and shut down their
metabolism
that can extend their lifetime
imagine if we can sleep through the
months-long journey to mars but that is
something that happens way later we have
to really understand
the origins first and the evolution
before we can do anything else
that's where the new fossil comes into
play it starts to fill in some of the
tardigrade's 500 million year history
paleontologists stumbled upon it in a
small piece of amber or fossilized tree
resin from the dominican republic
[Music]
yes it's very pretty but instead of
looking for mosquitoes carrying dino dna
these researchers were looking for ants
which you can see here
then under the microscope their eyes
turned to a small speck on the bottom
left let's zoom in that's the ancient
tardigrade right here
and it belongs to a whole new species
that's part of why this mini blob of a
specimen is so exciting
to study the ancient tardigrade a
graduate student in javier's lab put it
under a special microscope the way it
works is super cool so hold on to your
butt it uses lasers to take super high
resolution images when the laser hits
the fossilized tardigrade the beam
excites molecules that make it up the
excited molecules give off light the
microscope captures to create an image
see those colors
the colors are telling you basically how
far or how close the animal is relative
to you so if it's blue it's further away
and if it's red it's closer to you a
little bit like telescopes and
space you know using this technique
javier's graduate student was able to
capture the dominican tardigrade from
different angles
thing
like
just was beautiful like in great detail
and not only the whole body and from
different directions but also he was
able to get this
super nice fine detail of the claws
themselves
that's important because scientists use
the structure of the clause to figure
out what kind of tardigrade they have in
front of them
when the fossil photoshoot was all said
and done the researchers had also gotten
close-ups of the animal's throat and
other body parts it is the first time
ever that a fossil target rate has been
imaged with this level of resolution and
all this testing led them to discover
one big difference the fossil tardigrade
lacks certain tiny structures in the
throat that their currently living
relatives have
plus a similarity they both have these
needle-like structures they use for
feeding they basically
stick these needles out and they they
suck the juices out of like cells right
these observations led them to conclude
the new tardigrade whose name is
paradori for reviews
chrono caribales
it's actually not all that different
from tardigrades that still exist today
and that's a big insight evolution can
be quite rapid but it can also be quite
slow in some cases we can imagine 16
million years ago in the caribbean like
you had like some similar animals
kicking around and that that has its own
evolutionary value to it so what does
all this mean well it's another reminder
of what makes these animals so special
and it's an important step towards
figuring out how these tough little
creatures came to be and why they can
survive almost anywhere
the new fossil will go to the american
museum of natural history in new york
david grimaldi an ant specialist there
told me that tardigrade's extreme
survival skills like going dormant
during times of stress might actually
help them stay the same over millions of
years
animals adapt to survive and tardigrades
are masters of survival
if you want to learn more about extreme
creatures check out the links down below
and if you haven't already click
subscribe so you don't miss any of our
updates hasta luego nos vemos pronto
gracias